‏ja
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح
قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استو
واعتدلوا ساووا الصفوف سدوا الفرج ريت ذا
لاين
استووا الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ولو اننا نزلنا اليهم
الملائكه وكلمهم الموتى وحشرنا عليهم كل
شيء قبلا ما كانوا ليؤمنوا الا ان يشاء
الله ولكن اكثرهم
يجهلون وكذلك جعلنا لكل لنبي عدوا شياطين
الانس والجن يوحي
بعضهم يوحي بعضهم الى بعض زخرف القول
غرورا ولو شاء ربك ما فعلوه فذرهم وما
يفترون ولتصغى اليه افئده الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره وليرضوه
وليقترفوا ما هم
مقترفون افغير الله ابتغي
حكما وهو الذي انزل اليكم الكتاب
مفصلا والذين اتيناهم الكتاب يعلمون انه
منزل من ربك
بالحق فلا
تكونن من الممترين
وتمت كلمه ربك صدقا وعدلا لا مبدل لكلماته
وهو السميع
العليم وان تطع اكثر من في الارض يضلوك عن
سبيل
الله ان يتبعون الا الظن وان هم الا
يخرصون ان ربك هو اعلم من يضل عن سبيله
وهو اعلم بالمهتدين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ان ربك هو اعلم من يضل عن سبيله وهو اعلم
بالمهتدين
فكلوا مما ذكر اسم الله عليه ان كنتم
باياته
مؤمنين وما لكم الا تاكلوا مما ذكر اسم
الله عليه وقد فصل لكم ما حرم عليكم الا
ما اضطررتم
اليه وان كثيرا ليضلون
باهوائهم بغير علم ان ربك هو اعلم
بالمعتدين
وذروا ظاهر الاثم
وباطنه ان الذين يكسبون الاثم سيجزون بما
كانوا
يقترفون ولا تاكلوا مما لم يذكر اسم الله
عليه
وانه لفسق وان الشياطين ليوحون الى
اوليائهم ليجادلوكم وان اطعتموهم
انكم
لمشركون اونن كان
ميتا
فاحييناه اومن
كان
ميتا فاحييناه وجعلنا له نورا يمشي به في
الناس ككم مثله في الظلمات ليس بخارج
منها كذلك زين للكافرين ما كانوا
يعملون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن من
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام think ask
again ‏but
l any what i about just take
thein 7000
[Silence]
‏that
from perec are do make sa need and
desir
commun
us
what the second impr been
‏us to have around and all either
aent our
our team who is b sitting is do a
wonderful job so anyway i want to
say so it's really good alam and i know
that lot of it go to credit go to
brother ja again because he has provided
several rooms for the b sitting and he
assured the kids be locked away from the
mus
‏don't
[Silence]
‏sisterss is there you can see the
windows you can use room as long as with
your child you can be in that room and
please make sure that everything is
where supposed to be when you leave we
have a sister in there who going to be
helping from frid open الله
but have
[Silence]
استووا
اعتدلوا
استووا استووا
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وكذلك جعلنا في كل قريه كابر مجرميها
ليمكروا فيها وما يمكرون الا
بانفسهم وما
يشعرون واذا
جاءتهم ايه قالوا لن نؤمن حتى نؤتى مثل ما
اوتي رسل
الله الله اعلم حيث يجعل
رسالته سيصيب الذين اجرموا صغار عند الله
وعذاب شديد بما كانوا
يمكرون فمن يرد الله ان يهديه يشرح صدره
للاسلام ومن يرد ان يضله يجعل صدره ضيقا
حرجا كانما يصعد في
السماء كذلك يجعل الله الرجس على الذين لا
يؤمنون
وهذا صراط ربك مستقيما قد فصلنا الايات
لقوم
يذكرون لهم دار السلام عند
ربهم وهو وليهم بما كانوا
يعملون ويوم يحشرهم جميعا يا معشر الجن قد
استكثرتم من
الانس وقال
اولياؤهم من الانس ربنا استمتع بعضنا ببعض
وبلغنا اجلنا الذي اجلت لنا قال النار
مثواكم خالدين فيها الا ما شاء
الله ان ربك حكيم
عليم ان ربك حكيم عليم وكذلك نولي بعض
الظالمين بعضا بما كانوا
يكسبون يا معشر الجن والانس الم ياتكم رسل
منكم يقصون عليكم اياتي
وينذرونكم لقاء يومكم
هذا قالوا شهدنا على
انفسنا وغرتهم الحياه الدنيا وشهدوا على
انفسهم انهم كانوا
كافرين ذلك بان ربك لم يكن مهلك القرى
بظلم واهلها
غافلون ذلك بان لم يكن ربك مهلك القرى
غافلون و
ذلك بان لم يكن ربك مهلك القرى ذلك ان لم
يكن ربك مهلك القرى بظلم واهلها
غافلون ولكل
درجات مما عملوا وما ربك بغافل عما
يعملون وربك الغني ذو الرحمه ان يشا يذهب
ويستخلف من بعدكم ما
يشاء كما
انشاكم من ذريه قوم
اخرين انما توعدون لات
وما انتم
بمعجزين الله اكب
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
قل يا قوم اعملوا على مكانتكم اني عامل
فسوف تعلمون من تكون له عاقبه
الدار انه لا يفلح
الظالمون وجعلوا لله مما ذرا من الحرث
والانعام نصيبا فقالوا هذا لله بزعمهم
وهذا لشركائنا
فما كان
لشركائهم فهو يصل الى الله وما كان لله
فهو يصل الى
شركائهم فما كان
لشركائهم فلا يصل الى الله وما كان لله
فهو يصل الى
شركائهم ساء ما
يحكمون وكذلك زين لكثير من المشركين قتل
اولادهم
شركاؤهم ليردوهم وليلبسوا عليهم
دينهم ولو شاء الله ما فعلوه فذرهم وما
يفترون وجعلوا لله مما ذرا من الحرث
والانعام
نصيبا وقالوا هذه انعام وحرث حجر لا
يطعمها الا من نشاء
بزعمهم وانعام حرمت ظهورها وانعام لا
يذكرون اسم الله عليها
افتراء
عليه سيجزيهم بما كانوا
يفترون وقالوا ما في بطون هذه الانعام
خالصه لذكورنا ومحرم على
ازواجنا وان يكن ميته
فهم فيه
شركاء سيجزيهم
وصفهم انه حكيم
عليم قد خسر الذين قتلوا اولادهم سفها
بغير علم وحرموا ما رزقهم الله
افتراء على
الله قد ضلوا وما كانوا
مهتدين الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وهو الذي انشا جنات معروشات وغير
معروشات والنخل والزرع مختلفا اكله
والزيتون والرمان متشابها وغير
متشابه كلوا من ثمره اذا اثمر واتوا حقه
يوم حصاده ولا تسرفوا انه لا يحب المسرفين
ومن الانعام
حموله وفرشا كلوا مما رزقكم الله ولا
تتبعوا خطوات الشيطان انه لكم عدو
مبين ثمانيه
ازواج من الضان اثنين ومن المعز اثنين قل
ا الذكرين حرم ام الانثيين ام ما اشتملت
عليه ارحام
الانثيين نبئوني بعلم ان كنتم
صادقين ومن الابل اثنين ومن البقر اثنين
قل
ان الذكرين حرم ام
الانثيين اما اشتملت عليه ارحام
الانثيين ام كنتم شهداء اذ وصاكم الله
بهذا فمن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
ليض فمن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
ليضل الناس بغير
علم ان الله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين قل لا اجد فيما اوحي الي محرما
على طاعم يطعمه الا ان يكون ميته او دما
مسفوحا او لحم
خنزير او لحم خنزير فانه رجس او فسقا اهل
لغير الله به فمن الضر غير باغ ولا عاد
فان ربك غفور
رحيم وعلى الذين هادوا حرمنا كل ذي ظفر
ومن البقر والغنم حرمنا عليهم شحومهما
ومن البقر والغنم حرمنا عليهم شحومهما الا
ما حملت ظهورهما او الحوايا او ما اختلط
بعظم ذلك جزيناهم ببغيهم وانا
لصادقون فان كذبوك فقل ربكم ذو رحمه واسعه
ولا يرد باسه عن القوم
المجرمين سيقول الذين اشركوا لو
شاء الله ما اشركنا ولا
اباؤنا ولا حرمنا من
شيء سيقول الذين اشركوا لو شاء الله ما
اشركنا ولا ابا
ولا حرمنا من شيء كذلك كذب الذين من قبلهم
حتى ذاقوا باسنا قل هل عندكم من علم
فتخرجوه لنا ان تتبعون الا الظن وان انتم
الا
تخرصون قل فلله الحجه
البالغه فلو شاء لهداكم اجمعين
قل هلم
شركاءكم الذين يشهدون ان الله حرم
هذا قل هلم
شهداءكم الذين يشهدون ان الله حرم هذا فان
شهدوا فلا تشهد
معهم ولا تتبع
اهواء الذين كذبوا باياتنا والذين لا
يؤمنون بالاخره وهم بربهم
يعدلون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل تعالوا اتل ما حرم ربكم عليكم الا
تشركوا به شيئا وبالوالدين
احسانا ولا تقتلوا اولادكم من املاق نحن
نرزقكم
واياهم ولا تقربوا الفواحش ما ظهر منها
وما بطن ولا تقتلوا النفس التي حرم الله
الا
بالحق ذلكم
وصاكم به لعلكم
تعقلون ولا تقربوا مال اليتيم الا بالتي
هي احسن حتى يبلغ اشده واوف الكي والميزان
بالقسط لا نكلف نفسا الا
وسعها واذا قلتم فاعدلوا ولو كان ذا قربى
وبعهد الله اوفوا ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم
تذكرون وان هذا صراطي مستقيما
فاتبعوه ولا تتبعوا السبل فتفرق بكم عن
سبيله ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم
تتقون ثم اتينا موسى الكتاب تماما على
الذي احسن وتفصيلا لكل شيء وهدى
ورحمه وهدى ورحمه لعلهم بلقاء ربهم
يؤمنون وهذا كتاب ان ناه مبارك فاتبعوه
واتقوا لعلكم
ترحمون ان تقولوا انما انزل الكتاب على
طائفتين من قبلنا وان كنا عن دراستهم
لغافلين او تقولوا لو انا انزل علينا
الكتاب لكنا اهدى
منهم فقد
جاءكم بينه من ربكم وهدى ورحمه فمن اظلم
ممن كذب بايات الله وصدف عنها سنجزي الذين
يصدفون عن اياتنا سوء العذاب بما كانوا
يصدفون هل ينظرون الا ان تاتيهم الملائكه
او ياتي ربك او ياتي بعض ايات
ربك يوم ياتي بعض ايات ربك لا ينفع نفسا
ايمانها لم تكن امنت من قبل او كسبت في
ايمانها
خيرا قل انتظروا انا
منتظرون ان الذين فرقوا دينهم كانوا شيعا
لست منهم في شيء انما امرهم الى الله ثم
ينبئهم بما كانوا
يفعلون من جاء بالحسنه فله عشر
امثالها ومن جاء بالسيئه فلا يجزى الا
مثلها وهم لا
يظلمون قل انني هداني رب ربي الى صراط
مستقيم دينا قيما مله ابراهيم حنيفا وما
كان من
المشركين قل ان صلاتي ونسكي ومحياي ومماتي
لله رب
العالمين لا شريك له وبذلك امرت وانا اول
المسلمين قل اغير الله ابغي ربا وهو رب كل
شيء ولا تكسب كل نفس الا عليها ولا تزر
وازره وزر اخرى ثم الى ربكم مرجعكم
فينبئكم بما كنتم فيه
تختلفون وهو الذي جعلكم
خلائف الارض ورفع بعضكم فوق بعض
درجات ليبلوكم فيما
اتاكم ان ربك سريع العقاب وانه لغفور
رحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله وصحبه ومن ولاه ومن تبع باحسان
الى ي الدين
بعد شا
اللهد
ربم ‏f
more الله
سبالان للناس
حسنا سه البقره الله سبحانه
وتال حديث رسول الله ى الله عليه
وسلم ولم من لم ي قول زور وعمل به فلس لله
حاجه ان يدعوا طعامه وشرابه
‏whoever does notal spe ev while fasting
الله no for
him food or
drink sisters i request if you guys can
just c down a little b of times in the
front the sisters cann hear
you sisters
[Silence]
‏tak
mind mind
[Silence]
‏not that all
per and
i one of two things for all pr
life the
[Silence]
‏might beun c up
99.9% that
‏clear you
know try
toet justes out that h the
point don't
regate make
[Silence]
‏fasting not
fing and
‏anding
[Silence]
all how
‏here i won
name to me
wh
the
h hand
‏was
dates one two dates they
on so avoiding lying
anding first and
for arguing and backbiting and useless
talk a lot of times when we get together
we have things to say that
nos
no the is happing ‏how
bit are tesla not
tesla what talk say aric
think كلام
فض واللام فض there no use for
it ess
talk me saying something happ is not
change the world
[Silence]
حث صل
ان
حثث
f that's
الله
[Silence]
‏people care
ال محد
ر
ل 20
[Silence]
حث
شده
ح ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وكنا عذاب النار وكنا عذاب القبر
وكنا عذاب جنم وكنا شر فتنه المحيا الممات
وكنا ش فتنه المسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل مننا
انك السميع العليم وتب علينا يا مك تواب
الرحيم وصلى على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحمتك ارحم الراحمين اللهم امين
اللهم امين اللهم امين جزك
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف سدوا
الخلل
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الم م
ص كتاب انزل اليك من ربك فلا يكن في صدرك
حرج
منه كتاب انزل اليك فلا يكن في صدرك حرج
منه لتنذر به وذكرى
للمؤمنين اتبعوا ما انزل اليكم
من ربكم ولا تتبعوا من دونه
اولياء قليلا ما
تذكرون وكم من قريه اهلكناها
فجاءها باسنا بياتا او هم
قائلون فما كان دعواهم اذ
جاءهم باسنا الا الا ان قالوا الا ان
قالوا انا كنا
ظالمين فلنسالن
الذين ارسل اليهم ولنسالن
المرسلين فلنقصن
عليهم بعلم وما كنا
غائبين والوزن يومئذ الحق فمن ثقلت
موازينه فاولئك هم
المفلحون ومن خفت
موازينه
فاولئك الذين خسروا
انفسهم فاولئك الذين خسروا
انفسهم بما كانوا باياتنا
يظلمون ولقد خلق
ولقد
مكناكم في الارض وجعلنا لكم فيها معايش
قليلا ما
تشكرون ولقد خلقناكم ثم
صورناكم ثم قلنا
للملائكه اسجدوا لادم الا ابليس لم يكن من
الساجدين واذ قلنا
للملائكه اسجدوا لادم فسجدوا الا ابليس لم
يكن من
الساجدين قال ما منعك الا تسجد اذ
امرتك قال انا خير منه خلقتني من نار
وخلقته من طين قال فاهبط منها فما يك لك
ان تتكبر
فيها فاخرج انك من
الصاغرين قال
انظرني الى يوم
يبعثون قال انك من
المنظرين قال فبما اغويتني
لاقعدن لهم صراطك
المستقيم ثم لا
ينهم من بين ايديهم ومن خلفهم وعن
ايمانهم وعن ايمانهم وعن
شمائلهم ولا تجد اكثرهم
شاكرين قال اخرج منها مذو ما
مدحورا فمن تبعك منهم لاملج
جهنم منكم
اجمعين لمن تبعك منهم
لاملان جهنم منكم
اجمعين ويا ادم اسكن انت وزوجك الجنه فكلا
من حيث
شئتما ولا تقربا هذه الشجره فتكونا من
الظالمين
فوسوس لهما الشيطان ليبدي لهما ما وي من
عنهما ليبدي لهما ما ووري عنهما من
سوءاتهما وقال ما نهاكما ربكما عن هذه
الشجره الا الا ان تكونا ملكين او تكونا
من الخالدين
وقاسمهما
اني لكما لمن
الناصحين فدلاهما
بغرور فلما ذاق الشجره بدت لهما
سوءاتهما وطفقا يخصفان عليهما من ورق
الجنه
وناداهما ربه ما الم انهكما عن تلكما
الشجره واقل لكما واقل لكما ان الشيطان
لكما عدو
مبين قال ربنا ظلمنا انفسنا وان لم تغفر
لنا وترحمنا
لنكونن من
الخاسرين قال اهبطوا بعضكم لبعض عدو ولكم
في الارض مستقر ومتاع الى
حين قال فيها تحيون وفيها تموتون ومنها
تخرجون يا بني ادم قد
انزلنا عليكم لباسا يواري سوءاتكم
وريشا ولباس التقوى ذلك
خير ذلك من ايات الله لعلهم
يذكرون يا بني ادم لا
يفتننكم الشيطان كما اخرج ابويكم من
الجنه كما اخرج
ابويكم من الجنه ينزع عنهما لباس ما
ليريهما
سوءاتهما
انه يراكم هو
وقبيله من حيث لا
ترونهم انا جعلنا الشياطين
اولياء للذين لا
يؤمنون واذا فعلوا
فاحشه قالوا وجدنا عليها اباء
قالوا وجدنا عليها
اباءنا والله امرنا بها قل ان الله لا
يامر بالفحشاء
اتقولون على الله ما لا
تعلمون قل امر ربي بالقسط واقيموا وجوهكم
واقيموا وجوهكم عند كل مسجد وادعوه مخلصين
له
الدين قل امر ربي بالقسط واقيموا وجوهكم
عند كل مسجد وادعوه مخلصين له
الدين كما بداكم
تعودون فريقا هدى وفريقا حق عليهم
الضلاله
انهم اتخذوا الشياطين
اولياء من دون
الله
ويحسبون
انهم
مهتدون الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا بني ادم خذوا زينتكم عند كل مسجد
وكلوا واشربوا ولا تسرفوا
ولا تسرفوا انه لا يحب المسرفين قل من حرم
زينه الله التي اخرج لعباده
والطيبات من
الرزق قل هي للذين امنوا في الحياه الدنيا
خالصه يوم
القيامه كذلك نفصل الايات لقوم
يعلمون قل انما حرم ربي الفواحش ما ظهر
منها وما بطن والاثم والبغي بغير الحق وان
تشركوا بالله ما لم ينزل به
سلطانا وان تقولوا على الله ما لا
تعلمون ولكل امه اجل فاذا جاء اجلهم لا
يستقدمون ساعه ولا لا يستاخرون
ساعه ولا
يستقدمون يا بني ادم قد
انزلنا يا بني ادم اما
ياتينكم رسل
منكم يقصون عليكم اياتي
فمن اتقى واصلح فلا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون والذين كذبوا
باياتنا واستكبروا عنها
اولئك اصحاب
النار
اولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها
خالدون فمن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
او كذب
باياته
اولئك ينالهم
نصيبهم من
الكتاب حتى اذا
جاءتهم رسلنا
يتوفونهم قالوا اينما
كنتم قالوا اينما
كنتم تدعون من دون الله
قالوا ضلوا
عنا وشهدوا على
انفسهم انهم كانوا
كافرين قال ادخلوا في امم قد خلت من قبلكم
من الجن والانس في
النار كلما دخلت امه لعنت اختها حتى اذا
اداركوا فيه
جميعا حتى اذا اداركوا فيها جميعا قالت
اخراهم
لاولاهم قالت اخراهم لاولاهم ربنا
هؤء ضلو فاتهم
عذابا فاتهم
عذابا ضعفا من
النار قال كل ضعف ولكن لا
تعلمون وقالت اولاهم لاخراهم فما كان لكم
علينا من
فضل فذوقوا العذاب بما
كنتم
تكسبون ان الذين كذبوا باياتنا واستكبروا
عنها لا تفتح لا تفتح م ابواب
السماء ولا يدخلون
الجنه ولا يدخلون
الجنه حتى يلج الجمل في سم
الخياط وكذلك نجزي
المجرمين لهم من جهنم مهاد ومن فوقهم
غواش كذلك نجزي
الظالمين والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لا
نكلف نفسا الا
وسعها
اولئك اصحاب
الجنه هم فيها
خالدون ونزعنا ما في
صدورهم من غل تجري من تحت م
الانهار وقالوا الحمد لله الذي هدانا
لهذا وقالوا الحمد لله الذي هدانا لهذا
وما كنا لنهتدي لولا ان هدانا الله لقد
جاءت رسل ربنا
بالحق ونودوا ان تلكم
الجنه ونودوا ان تلكم الجنه اورثتموها بما
كنتم
تعملون ونادى اصحاب الجنه اصحاب النار ان
قد وجدنا ما وعدنا ربنا
حقا فهل وجدتم ما وعد ربكم حقا
قالوا نعم فاذن
مؤذن بينهم ال لعنه الله على
الظالمين الذين يصدون عن سبيل الله
ويبغونها
عوجا وهم بالاخره
كافرون
وبينهما
حجاب وعلى الاعراف رجال يعرف
كلا
بسيماهم ونادوا اصحاب الجنه ان سلام
عليكم ان سلام عليكم لم يدخلوها وهم
يطمعون واذا صرفت ابصارهم
تلقاء اصحاب النار قالوا
ربنا قالوا ربنا
تجعلنا مع القوم
الظالمين ونادى اصحاب الاعراف رجالا
يعرفونهم
بسيماهم قالوا ما اغنى عنكم جمعكم وما
كنتم
تستكبرون
اهؤلاء الذين اقسمتم لا ينالهم الله برحمه
ادخلوا
الجنه لا خوف عليكم ولا انتم
تحزنون ونادى اصحاب النار اصحاب الجنه ان
افيضوا علينا من
الماء ونادى اصحاب النار اصحاب الجنه ان
افيضوا علينا من الماء
او مما رزقكم
الله قالوا ان الله حرمهما على
الكافرين الذين اتخذوا دينهم لهوا ولعبا
وغرتهم الحياه الدنيا فاليوم
ننساهم كما نسوا لقاء يومهم هذا
ما كانوا
باياتنا
يجحدون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الددين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ونادى اصحاب النار اصحاب الجنه ان افيضوا
علينا من
الماء او مما رزقكم الله قالوا ان الله
حرمهما على
الكافرين الذين اتخذوا دينهم لهوا ولعبا
وغرتهم الحياه الدنيا
فاليوم
ننساهم كما نسوا
لقاء يومهم هذا وما كانوا
باياتنا
يجحدون ولقد جئناهم بكتاب فصلناه على علم
هدى ورحمه لقوم
يؤمنون هل ينظرون الا
تاويله يوم ياتي تاويله يقول الذين نسوه
من
قبل يقول الذين نسوه من قبل قد جاءت رسل
ربنا
بالحق فهل لنا من
شفعاء فيشفعوا لنا او نرد فنعمل غير الذي
كنا نعمل قد خسروا انفسهم وضل عنهم ما
كانوا
يفترون ان ربكم الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض في سته ايام ثم استوى على العرش
يغشي
الليلا نهار يطلبه
حثيثا والشمس والقمر
والنجوم
مسخرات بامره الا له الخلق وال الامر
تبارك الله رب
العالمين ادعوا ربكم تضرعا وخفيه
انه لا يحب المعتدين ولا تفسدوا في الارض
بعد
اصلاحها وادعوه
خوفا
وطمعا ان رحمه الله قريب من المح سنين وهو
الذي يرسل الرياح بشرا بين يدي رحمته حتى
اذا حتى اذا اقلت سحابا ثقالا سقناه لبلد
ميت سقناه لبلد ميت
فانزلنا به الماء فاخرجنا به من كل
الثمرات
كذلك نخرج الموتى لعلكم
تذكرون والبلد الطيب يخرج نباته باذن ربه
والذي خبث لا يخرج الا نكدا كذلك نصرف
الايات لقوم
يشكرون لقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه فقال يا
قوم اعب ادوا الله ما
لكم فقال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من
اله غيره اني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم عظيم
قال الملا من قومه انا لنراك في ضلال
مبين قال يا قوم ليس بي ضلاله ولا لكني
رسول من رب
العالمين ابلغكم رسالات ربي وانصح لكم
واعلم من الله ما لا
تعلمون اوعجبتم ان
جاءكم ذكر من ربكم على رجل منكم
لينذركم
لينذركم ولتتبع
لكم ترحمون فكذبوه
فانجيناه والذين معه في
الفلك واغرقنا الذين كذبوا
باياتنا انهم كانوا قوما عمين والى عاد
اخاهم هى قال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم
من اله غيره افلا تت
تون قال الملا الذين كفروا من قومه انا
لنراك في سفاهه وانا
لنظ من
الكاذبين قال يا قوم ليس بي سفاهه
ولكني رسول من رب
العالمين ابلغكم رسالات ربي وانا لكم ناصح
امين اوعجبتم ان جاءكم ذكر من ربكم على
رجل منكم
لينذركم واذ واذكروا اذ جعلكم
خلفاء من بعد قوم نوح وزادكم في الخلق
بسطه فاذكروا الاء الله لعل
تفلحون قالوا اجئتنا لنعبد الله وحده ونذر
ما كان يعبد
اباؤنا فاتنا بما
تعدنا ان كنت من
الصادقين قال قد وقع عليكم من ربكم رجس
وغضب اتجادلونني في اسماء ان
سميتموها
سميتموها انتم
واباؤكم ما نزل الله بها من
سلطان
فانتظروا اني معكم من
المنتظرين
فانجيناه والذين معه
برحمه
منا وقطعنا دابر الذين كذبوا
باياتنا وما كانوا
مؤمنين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والى ثمود دا اخاهم
صالحا قال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من
اله غيره قد
جاءتكم بينه من
ربكم هذه ناقه الله لكم
ايه فلا ولا تمسوها
بسوء فياخذ عذاب اليم
هذه ناقه الله لكم ايه فذروها تاكل في ارض
فذروها تاكل في ارض الله ولا تمسوها
بسوء في ياخذكم عذاب اليم واذكروا اذ
جعلكم
خلفاء من بعد عاد
وبوا وبوا في الارض تتخ ذون من سهولها
قصورا وتنحتون الجبال
بيوتا واذكروا
الاء الله ولا تعثوا في الارض
مفسدين فاذكروا
مفسدين قال الملا الذين استكبروا من قومه
للذين استضعفوا لمن امن منهم
اتعلمون اتعلمون ان صالحا مرسل من
ربه قالوا انا بما ارسل به
مؤمنون قال الذين استكبروا انا بالذي
امنتم به
كافرون فعقر الناقه وعتوا عن امر ربهم
وقالوا يا صالح ائتنا بما
تعدنا وقالوا يا صالح ائتنا بما تعدنا ان
كنت من
المرسلين فاخذتهم الرجفه فاصبحوا في دارهم
جاثمين فتولى عنهم وقال يا قوم لقد
ابلغتكم رساله ربي ونصحت لكم ولكن لا
تحبون
الناصحين ولوطا اذ قال لقومه اتاتون
الفاحشه ما سبقكم بها من احد من
العالمين انكم لتاتون الرجال شهوه من دون
النساء
بل
انتم قوم
مسرفون وما كان جواب قومه الا ان قالوا
اخرجوهم من
قريتكم انهم اناس
يتطهرون
فانجيناه واهله الا امراته كانت من
الغابرين وامطر
عليهم
مطرا
وامطرنا عليهم مطرا ف فانظر كيف كان
عاقبه
المجرمين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
‏somebody l
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل
السو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهد الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى فجعله
غثاء اح
سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء الله انه يعلم
الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان
نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم
لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم وموسى
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل يا ايها الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد ولا انا عابد ما عبدتم ولا انت انتم
عابدون ما
اعبد لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا اللهم صل
على سيدنا محمد في الاولين وصل على سيدنا
محمد في
الاخرين وصل على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت
وحين اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد حتى
ترث الارض ومن عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم تم نورك فهديت فلك الحمد
عظم حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت يدك فاعطيت
فلك الحمد اللهم تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علي يا ربنا انك انت التواب
الرحيم اللهم تقبل صيامنا اللهم تقبل
صيامنا
وصلاتنا
وقراننا وصالح اعمالنا لوجهك الكريم اللهم
تقب تقبلها منا خالصه لوجهك
الكريم اللهم انا نسالك بكل خير س لك منه
عبدك ورسولك محمد اللهم انا نسالك من كل
خير سالك منه عبدك ورسولك محمد وعبادك
الصالحون ونعوذ بك من كل شر استعاذك منه
عبدك ورسولك محمد وعبادك الصالحون اللهم
انا نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك
انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك ان تجعل
القران العظيم ربيع
صدورنا ونور قلوبنا وجلاء
احزاننا وذهاب همومنا وذهاب همومنا
وغمومنا وسابقنا الى جناتك جنات النعي
اللهم علمنا منه ما جهلناه وذكرنا منه ما
نفسينا وارزقنا تلاوته اناء الليل واطراف
النهار على الوجه الذي يرضيك
عنا برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم اعتق
رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا وازواجنا وذري
واخواننا ومن احبك فينا ومن احببناه فيك
ومن احبك فينا اللهم اعتق رقابنا جميعا من
النار اللهم فرج هم المهمومين ونفس كرب
المكروبين واقض الدين عن
المدينين واشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين
وارحم موتانا وموتى الم مسلمين برحمتك يا
ارحم الراحمين اللهم كل للمستضعفين من
المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم انك احصيت عددا
اللهم انك احصيت عددا ومكانا وحالا فكن
لهم ومعهم اينما كانوا يا رب
العالمين سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله ‏e